the first sign that Trump is beating
Democrats on actual issues like the
economy and crime is when they start
their distraction and deflection routine
it's so obvious at this point it's
actually getting boring they prefer to
have Biden hunker in the bunker as they
peddle stories that have zero effect on
your daily lives unbolted unleashing a
torrent of criticism against his former
boss he is not okay for the American
people calling him listen to his words
naive and dangerous little more than
6,000 people showed up Saturday and
Tulsa far below the expectations the
issue that drives the president more
than anything else on these rallies and
that is the crowd sighs why does he use
racist phrases like completely are you
saying the White House does not believe
it embrace it now Biden doesn't need of
course to worry about his crowd sizes
because he doesn't do rallies at all
last week's Pennsylvania event wasn't
even open to the public but only 220
local officials and small business
owners handpicked by the campaign that's
convenient and in the arena though the
Trump campaigns magnetometer of course
showed 12 not 6,000 in attendance as was
widely reported by the press but
regardless an eye-popping 11 point seven
million people watched Trump's rally on
TV and online Trump gave Fox News its
highest Saturday night ratings in
network history but the main point is I
think 20 years from now no one's going
to be writing about things like John
Bolton's bitter neocon ramblings no
one's going to be writing about the
specific crowd size at a single
presidential rally and no one's gonna
care what nicknames were given to a
pandemic but historians if they're
honest will note how in 2020 Trump stood
up to defend the greatness of America as
roving bands of neo-marxist ripped down
historical markers in states and cities
run by liberals and they'll also report
how the people had
vote on any of this and how as I
predicted weeks ago the destruction went
far beyond the original Confederate
targets videos posted to social media
show the moment Francis Scott Key was
dragged to the ground he wrote the
lyrics to the star-spangled banner he
was also a slave owner protestors
knocked down the statue a former
president and Civil War General Ulysses
Grant and the statue of Junipero Serra
in an exclusive interview with Raymond
Arroyo President Trump was quick to
point out what all the chaos engulfed
cities have in common whether it's
Chicago its Democrat Seattle its
Democrat the state of Washington it's
Democrat Portland its Democrat all of
these places are run by Democrats 20 out
of 20 a Democrat run they don't know
what they're doing and if Biden got in
this country would be a disaster we'll
have more from Raymond's exclusive
interview with the president later on in
the hour but seriously what Republican
when you really think about this other
than Trump would have defied the media
and to find even some local officials to
be with his supporters I think he did it
to show people that life has to go on
that business the business of America
must go on and that the campaigning must
go on
and of course that we cannot stay hidden
forever and separated from one another
as the Democrats want now just imagine a
Republican like let's say Mitt Romney if
you were running he'd be speaking to you
from the comfort of home muffled behind
his mask and espousing cliches about
alone together now imagine the
enthralled dozens who would tune in for
that now better than anyone else on the
political scene today Trump knows how
important it is to identify frame and
win the current culture wars leftist
radicals in Portland Oregon ripped down
a statue of George Washington
and wrapped it in an American flag and
set the American flag on fire
Democrat I'm old Democrat everything I
tell you is Democrat and you know we
ought to do something we should have
legislation that if somebody wants to
burn the American flag and stomp on it
but just burn it they go to jail for one
year well he also properly defined Joe
Biden for what he is
a figurehead and a feeble one at that
Joe Biden is surrendered to his party
and to the left-wing mob he has no
control does anybody honestly think he
controls these radical maniacs Joe Biden
is not the leader of his party Joe Biden
is a helpless puppet of the radical left
bingo
the Trump campaign seems to get it this
isn't an election between Trump and
Biden it's between Trump and the far
left that's captured the Democrat Party
finally I think by merely showing up in
Tulsa Trump demonstrated that he's not
going to be controlled by the kovat fear
mongers the media and his political
opponents they don't care about colvett
infections
give me a break for if they did they
would have shut down the George Floyd
protests in dozens and dozens of cities
across America but they didn't in the
Senate no none of them should be taken
seriously any more on this topic period
unless you're in in the crowd that's
maybe anti Trump they want you locked
down until the vaccine is available no
one's going to do that well smart states
have said no to all that and yes to
reopening more testing of course means
you're going to have more infections but
now that we see the true lethality of
the virus and the virus attenuating
along with the devastation that all the
lockdowns cause we're getting a clearer
picture of all this not surprising the
states that dragged out their shutdowns
are falling behind economically The Wall
Street Journal noting today that nine of
the ten states for the highest jobless
rates are run by
Democrats who've tended to demand that
the economy should stay locked down and
in some cases are still resisting
opening you can see them all listed here
not surprisingly witless Whitmer's state
of Michigan is number three on the list
with 21% unemployment California at 16%
jobless rate followed by New Jersey and
Illinois had a miserable 15 percent rate
now of course the state of the lowest
unemployment rate is Nebraska which is
controlled by Republicans and was never
under a statewide stay-at-home order
other states that never saw a lock down
still saw unemployment go up as the
national economy tanked but now every
single one of them is still better off
than those Democrat states I just showed
you the eight states that didn't fully
lock down had an average unemployment
rate of 9.1 percent still much lower
than the others I cited now this
shouldn't surprise any of us we trust
the people they want to control the
people we believe you can make your own
decisions decisions especially about
your health but they want to make them
for you they want to open America to a
flood of new workers at a time when so
many of you were still struggling to get
back on your feet african-americans and
Latinos especially need a president who
sees the importance of taking care of
Americans first and in that vein the
president today issued executive action
to immediately halt the issuing of new
visas to foreign non agricultural
workers now this is key to opening jobs
for Americans who desperately need them
the administration expects these new
restrictions to free up five hundred and
twenty thousand jobs five hundred
twenty-five thousand jobs for Americans
now contrary to what you'll hear from
the open borders media public opinion
shows traditionally huge support for
pauses and immigration a Washington Post
in University of Maryland poll from late
April found that 65 percent of those
polled support pausing immigration into
the country including 61% of minority
respondents in a Pew Research Center
poll found
81% of Americans see mass migration as a
threat as we confront the challenges
posed by the corona virus now while
immigration hawks like myself you know
we still want more
president Trump deserves huge credit for
standing up to the business lobby to
protect American workers the Democrats
will run in the opposite direction I
promise you for the past month
pretty much all you've seen on TV are
the people who vehemently hate what's at
the core of this country everything we
stand for you're seeing it tonight in
Lafayette Park in Washington but now I
think it's time that we see Americans
standing up to say hell no you won't and
by the way we'll have our say soon and
that's the angle